Hola María Clara la intención de
Guatemala de llevar a la justicia a los
estragos judiciales al actual ministro
de defensa Iván Velázquez tiene asidero
en la reactivación de un juicio en
contra de dos ex directivos de la
constructora brasileña odebrecht que
inició el pasado mes de noviembre y
quienes están citados a declarar el
próximo primero de febrero la red el
entramado de corrupción de odebrecht en
Guatemala comenzó en el año 2012 por el
cual habrían sido salpicados más de 100
congresistas quienes presuntamente
recibieron sobornos para adjudicar una
carretera de 400 millones de dólares a
la constructora brasileña justamente fue
este caso el que la investigación la
inició la cicija en cabeza de Iván
Velázquez una investigación en la que se
presume que estos dos ex directivos
brasileños habrían participado como
colaboradores eficaces lo que significa
que ellos habrían denunciado y narrado
Quiénes fueron los actores y los actos
de corrupción Entonces el actual fiscal
contra la impunidad Rafael currucciche
dice que tiene unos correos electrónicos
en los cuales asegura que es Iván
Velázquez quien aprobó estos acuerdos de
colaboración y Fica eficaz por los
cuales se denotaría que él tendría
conocimiento pleno de todos esos
negociaciones corruptas de odebrecht en
Guatemala bueno y cuando él presidió las
Y también fue como un campeón contra la
corrupción como muchos lo llamaron sin
embargo lo expulsaron del país en 2017
porque es tan controversial su figura
bueno efectivamente Jimmy Morales ordenó
la expulsión de Iván Velázquez en 2017
pero fue una decisión que reversó la
corte constitucional porque no alcanzó
pues la consulta de todos los ministros
Entonces no lo pudo finalmente expulsar
lo que sí fue que el año de un año
después en el 2018
ordenó que no se renovara el mandato de
la sicigia aprovechando una visita de
Iván Velázquez oficial en los Estados
Unidos luego le prohibió la entrada a
Guatemala Lo cierto es que Iván
Velázquez en todos esos años en cabeza
de la cicic desde el 2013 destapó
múltiples escándalos de corrupción uno
de ellos El más sonado fue en el 2015
toda la trama en contra del entonces
presidente Otto Pérez Molina quien por
Este descubrimiento que le hizo
Velázquez tuvo que renunciar someterse a
la justicia y el año pasado obtuvo una
condena de 16 años de prisión de manera
que la figura de Iván Velázquez en
Guatemala el colombiano es muy temida
pero también muy resentida por todos
aquellos actores involucrados en la
corrupción